we are not going to exhaustively explore
this matter because for one thing quite
a number of people have done extensive
explorations here and some of them are
so excellent that you really owe it to
yourself to look at them so i would
include in that chris martinson has done
uh an exploration
uh matthew 1 t crawford has done one
um
phil harper has done one and i will talk
touch on one of the points that he makes
uh in a couple of minutes here and
alexandros marinus has also done
an excellent a couple of analyses as
well as a thread in which he compiles
some of the analyses that other people
have done
and uh ivm meta you can show me right
you can show my screen here if if you
like which is a
relatively long-standing long-standing
with regard to covid
site uh has
you know has an ongoing exhaustive
description of what the various studies
show don't show what their weaknesses
are etc and um zach if you just put my
screen back on for a moment here
this with regard to
specifically the together study uh they
just have a number you know it's an
ongoing list many of which are points
that have been made by for instance
alexandros and matthew and chris and
such
um but uh just just to just to look at a
couple of them there are many basic
inconsistencies and protocol violations
there's no response to data requests
they've got different two different
death counts the trial was not blind
uh unequal randomization confounding my
time and then i skipped the second one
here which is delayed by six months and
i'm going to let you basically talk
about this for the most part the whole
thing but i did want to say that here on
ibm meta
they say the paper was delayed every six
months with no explanation so this is
this um this this big study um the
results were revealed back in august of
2021 and then i think it was the
fluoxamine arm which was published
within a couple weeks
and then nothing and so there are a lot
of people who upon hearing the results
which basically were
ivermectin is useless you know don't
bother uh we were you know we were right
all along not that that's what the
authors here said but that was the sort
of the take in the in the media
um
many everyone who cared about this
results immediately said well you know
i'm going to need to look at the at the
analysis um there's not even a way to
look at the data because the data still
aren't being um produced but um the
thing wasn't published for six months
and so ibm meta says
one possible reason would be rejection
from a series of journals which would be
expected given the issues it's a
possibility we have no idea if that's
true
uh you know that was not my guess as to
why it would have been delayed but yeah
but it is it is remarkable that suddenly
this week everyone is talking about this
as if this is as if this is news
um and it was you know it was news in
august and now we can see how really
unused it is because the study is so
flawed it's not even on news it's
anti-news and uh you know phil harper
addresses this very directly and so i
want to um
highlight his analysis do you have a
something to show yeah he's got well i
actually don't have something to show
but i would advise people to sign up for
his sub stack he has a seven day free
trial you can look at the whole thing
um but in any case
he um talks about you can just ch i've
just pulled it up and you've just pulled
it out yeah
so this is yeah um
so yeah he he says uh the can't add
together trial i would say they can't
even keep it together trial so
what iv meta raises as the possibility
for why this is so delayed that it was
rejected from multiple places before the
new england journal of medicine finally
accepted it
the reason that that doesn't quite add
up and strikes me as more more generous
than uh
than it needs to be is that were all of
the errors here to have been spotted
by
reviewer after reviewer and
journals to have passed on this that
would have forced them to be corrected
in a sense some of them are so basic the
errors are just simple arithmetic errors
right that if these things were being
caught
then it's hard to imagine how it could
have landed in such a high profile
journal in such a crazy state i mean
it's really just riddled with errors
so
that does suggest
that like so much in this landscape of
early treatment covid public health
policy and all that the distortions here
are about something it's the immense
gravitational force of some object we
cannot see right is that object simply
pharma profits we don't know but what we
know is that nothing works in this
landscape like it's supposed to and one
of the things that doesn't work is not
only was this
delayed it's not really even delayed the
point is the
punch line was given to us and then the
basis for that punchline was delayed by
more than six months so this thing was a
weapon in the hands of those who argued
that there was no utility to uh to this
particular early treatment this was a
weapon over that entire period without
our ability to discover how good a
weapon or how accurate it was and then
upon its release the point is okay
suddenly there's all this fanfare and
the wall street journal is publishing on
the fact that
this study finally you know remember you
were told randomized controlled trials
are the gold standard of science that's
what you were told right
well here is what you are now told is
the largest randomized controlled trial
that's been done on this topic
well technically
but it wasn't done well i mean this is
this is exactly this is the kind of
explicit and intentional and seems
category error that we've been talking
about across the board right like well
vaccines have been effective in reducing
rates of rates and of and deaths from
rabies cool therefore anything that we
call a vaccine for a particular uh
disease uh is something that you need uh
wait you know right so even if it were
true uh that randomized control trials
were the thing that you absolutely need
to demonstrate efficacy which it's which
is not true right um but that doesn't
mean that anything that calls itself a
randomized control trial is done well um
or you know it is done well at all and
to your point about you know the wall
street journal you know
every mainstream outlet is
very happy about this result that ought
to be giving us pause
why are people so pleased that early
treatment with with a drug that has a
long safety record is not effective
against what we are being told is the
worst scourge to hit humankind in a
hundred years that seems surprising um
but then we even have like this this
headline just struck me as particularly
remarkable so show my screen if you
would again zach this is from newsweek
what joe rogan has said defending
ivermectin as drug is ruled ineffective
ruled yeah now this is a headline author
and headlines are often crazy and um you
know presumably has nothing to do with
the person who wrote this and you can
get rid of that because it's now of
course of course here it's you know it's
showing trump right who has nothing to
do at all with ivermectin in fact he's
pro-vaccine right um
so um
what the headline writer reveals though
and no one who saw this at newsweek
before putting this up caught is that
they think this is about
it's like a court of law
it's like a standard of of
of proof like you would find in a court
of law ruled ruled ineffective that's
not how science works science doesn't
work
by uh by
democracy by vote that's that's not what
should be going on here and yet that is
clearly what we are seeing as this thing
finally gets published and suddenly
everyone who was so thrilled to be
talking about horse dewormer last summer
is back talking about all the same
things they've been talking about before
without actually
paying any attention to the fact that
the study itself is flawed you know i
don't even know how many at least 20
different ways yeah
and
presumably there are many out there who
didn't know what to think right who
probably did accept randomized
controlled trials are the gold standard
of science you know nobody having
thought through how many things were
never exposed to a randomized controlled
trial that we know
work how many things are incapable of
being exposed to randomized controlled
trial that we do science in other ways
um
but lots of people probably accepted oh
well randomized controlled trial is
certainly the best kind of science and
so oh this is the largest randomized
controlled trial done on this topic well
what did it say about ivermectin it says
it doesn't work right the problem is
a couple things one
randomized and controlled right
randomly assigning people to two groups
one of which is a placebo control
group which controls for effects that
are not part of the treatment right
this among the errors here are errors
that suggest that this was neither
randomized nor placebo controlled so
here's the question if randomized
control trial is the gold standard
this was not a randomized controlled
trial and yet according to the wall
street journal it's the largest
randomized controlled trial that's been
done on this topic so the point is
nothing in this
even superficially passes muster and
what's more
if you think about what was
you know one of the few good things
about the way the pandemic unfolded was
that at the very beginning of the
pandemic science was being done out in
the open was peer review happening well
review by peers was certainly happening
it was happening on this podcast and
elsewhere as people were looking at
science that was emerging that hadn't
yet gone through
the official process of peer review it
was amazing we talked about it it felt
like the wild west the pre-print servers
were just full they were just you know
hundreds more papers weekly and it was
extraordinary it was the actual studies
and were the actual studies all good no
but you could look at them and you could
say well here's what's wrong with this
one here you know oh this one actually
looks pretty good because they accounted
for the thing that would trip up you
know another methodology so actual
review by peers happened in this case
early on the later we have gotten the
more this has been inverted and i just
want to point out how perfectly the
inversion worked here the inversion
worked so that what we got here was not
the ability to scrutinize anything in
fact we were denied the ability to
scrutinize anything for more than six
months what we got was a conclusion that
matched somebody's desire right and then
the point was well
what are the chances that that's what
the study actually says and that it does
so on the basis of sound science and
sound philosophy of science right many
of us thought the chances were low but
there was no ability to do exactly what
we're supposed to do which is go in
there and look and say well how good was
your methodology your methodology could
be good maybe you didn't follow it how
good was your methodology and did you
follow it and in this case
um what we see is oh it's garbage long
after
the six month period in which people
portrayed this trial as definitive and
long after the wall street journal and
others touted this as well the evidence
is finally in right now what are the
chances that all of the people who got
suckered a few days ago
and saw the wall street journal touting
this are going to find phil harper or
alexandros mourinhos or chris martinson
or any of these people right the point
is
this is a way to sell a conclusion as
science-based when the science itself is
not robust
that's that's exactly right
um i was struck
uh
by actually one of the fines that
alexandros made
with regard to the the dosing
right so the protocol says
that the dosing given in the ivermectin
arm
was is it 400 micrograms per kilogram of
body weight for three days
but uh he went digging into the
supplement protocol supplement you know
again not the entire data set with the
protocol supplement and the
detail that he finds there is that
actually that's not true um that that's
only true up to body weights of 90
kilograms and then it sort of it just it
tops out and there's no justification
for that either given or anywhere else
in the ivermectin literature right and
what that means is that for people who
are frankly pretty much you know most
people above 90 kilograms are probably
overweight not all some people are tall
but
but in general
the
greater chances you have of being
overweight the greater chances you have
of having been underdosed uh in this
trial with regard to ivermectin and
there's nothing except hidden in the
supplement by someone who was really
trying to figure out what happened um to
indicate that at all and so you know it
it this is just one example and there
are lots of these examples but there's
just so many ways that the study did not
do what it claimed to do and then you
have places like newsweek saying well
basically the the jury came back yep and
it's like that's not what we're doing
here oh wait actually apparently it is
because the jury came back means
newsweek in the wall street journal the
new york times and huffpo and i'm just
making places up because i assume
everyone has written their ridiculous
piece except at the conclusion from the
authors or from you know new england
general americans press
medicines press release and um hasn't
taken the time and probably doesn't have
the the chops of the wherewithal to
actually go in and check or even to look
at you know any of these analyses that
have been done by the people you've
mentioned i would also point out that
this is not just a matter of lay people
not having the chops to go in right
it shouldn't be the case but scientists
all too frequently look at the title and
maybe the abstract of something and
assume that the work is done well and it
is amazing how frequently one goes into
a paper and one sees that actually even
the abstract isn't justified by the the
method section for example very often um
yeah it's really common
and you know methods methods are tough
if you're outside of your particular
field
and they're they're just they're hard to
read
but
they are necessary if you are actually
going to decide that what it is that the
authors have claimed uh is true
i would also point out that the one
thing i will say um you know by way of
steel manning this trial which i really
don't feel like deserves it because the
the number of things that everyone else
is still manning it for us yeah but even
so
just the number of things that are wrong
in the same direction does not suggest
good faith how that happened i don't
know but um it's it's conspicuous and so
you know my feeling is steel manning
only makes sense when the thing on the
other side
is a different perspective and you want
to give it its due but it doesn't really
have a do if it's if it's cheating
um but
uh what was i gonna say i was gonna say
um
oh yeah
it is very let us admit that
or just acknowledge that
a a study like this is hugely complex
right yes and it's not only complex at
the level of well what would the study
have to do and what things would have to
be compared in order to um to accomplish
the goal and you know lots of things
that viewers of this podcast will be
well familiar with like uh you know you
can sabotage a trial or you can screw it
up by treating too late right things
like that or you could in the case of
ivermectin you could give it um without
food so that it wouldn't uh cross the
gut as they did as they did right but
the point is there's lots of complexity
or they recommended that it be taken on
an empty stomach right what are the
chances that you would do a study of
this complexity without making some
errors i'd say they're effectively zero
yeah there will be some errors now it's
been a lot of months since the result
came out so you know there i think one
of the things was like there i don't
remember even what the numbers were it's
like was it 228 or 288 i don't even
remember where in there but well
you know typos happen
mistakes happen in the relating of
results if they happened in the original
data that's a big problem but also
there's been a lot of time for a lot of
people on a study this big with this
many authors to really go through and
check and check and check yeah and
there's also a right way to deal with it
either your study is uh so compromised
by the errors that you don't publish it
because it's not evidence or it's
compromised in a way that let's say you
lose some fraction of the individuals
who were in the study because they
discovered they were in the placebo
group for example and so it's that part
of the study is no longer placebo
controlled but some other group wasn't
aware right so then the point is then
you scale back what study you publish so
that the study you publish is actually
evidence of something right and
the point is okay they made errors
some of the errors may just be the
normal fact of a complex study but the
point is there's a right honorable way
to deal with the errors that you make in
a study such as that and that didn't
happen here it didn't happen at the
editor level it didn't happen at the
level of the peer reviewers it didn't
happen at the level of how this evidence
emerged into public you know it's one
thing to see a preprint where you get to
see the conclusion of the study and you
get to see how the study was done and
you can compare them it's another thing
to get to see the conclusion and not be
able to see how the study was done
there's no preprint and then then the
point is this is pr right this was
effectively
a psyop as so much in this neighborhood
has been and so anyway final thing i
want to say is
science is supposed to work right and i
don't mean science the philosophy of
science scientific method but science
the practice of science in modernity is
supposed to work on the basis that we
want things explored we society want
things explored we provide incentives
that come to those in a position to do
the work in the form of
jobs in the form of promotions in the
form of grants in the form of prizes
right all of these things are given for
high quality work that elucidates stuff
in a way that is good and those
incentives draw people to discover
things right
but if those incentives are not not
targeted at hey discover what the truth
of ivormectin is but they're targeted at
here's a story that we need to be
supported by science looking stuff they
can do that too if you give the prizes
and the jobs and the promotions and the
grants to people who come up with a
story that some very powerful entity
wants told then that's what science will
do and in this particular case we do
know that you know the apparatus
surrounding anthony fauci
is the behemoth of grant awarding right
that thing
is in a position to control a huge
fraction of the money which serves the
purpose of the incentive in the system
so what that has to do with how this
trial came about we don't know
but the fact that you would get a trial
that
claims to be essentially definitive by
claiming the mantle of what they have
called the gold standard which i will
argue is actually about something else
but we've been told randomized
controlled trial is the gold standard
right this trial
claims to be the largest randomized
controlled trial of this particular
treatment and it comes to a conclusion
that is well treatment doesn't work
right that is how you tell a story and
the fact that it wasn't a randomized
controlled trial
right
that it pretends to be one but isn't one
is part and parcel of what's going on
here so my my claim is going to be
that this idea that randomized control
trial is the gold standard
is actually
a
trope of sorts there is a way in which
it can be true if a randomized control
trial is done well
right if
if the philosophy of science underneath
it is sound if the methodology is good
and if the methodology is followed well
then it is going to be the best way to
elucidate especially a subtle pattern
right
however
i don't think that's why it is being
shoved at us as the gold standard it's
being shoved at us because it is the
most gameable right because just as a
good methodology uh is amplified by
randomized controlled trial a bad
methodology is too and
well it's gameable but i would say
another point in its favor in scare
quotes is that it can't be done by
individuals without uh large backing oh
right so you know you can't come in
and you know and try to understand the
study in retrospect the way that uh the
way that alexandra's and matthew and
phil and chris and you know and
are and that we have in a lot of other
places and you know that's that is as it
should be but in order to and and you
know we we have ourselves done not in
this not in the sphere um but a lot of
uh very low-tech low-cost science and in
fact i used to encourage this um not
just for myself for my students like you
you don't want something that's going to
require a lot of money because then then
you're not nimble then you can you know
then you can't move at the point that
your funders say actually i don't like
what you're doing anymore right and
that's not to say that there aren't
questions that deserve to be asked and
that are important for humanity that
they be asked and answered that require
a lot of money there are but there are
also a lot there's too many incentives
to push money towards being more
expensive than it needs to i say money
that pushes science towards being more
expensive than it needs to be
because that renders those people doing
the science incapable of getting out so
rcts randomized control trials we can't
do those right individuals can't do
those right individuals can't do that
you're right that's another from the
point of view of something that wishes
to control the narrative that is a major
feature right that they somebody can't
easily bootstrap one so they're highly
gameable methodologically
uh and individuals can't uh can't do
them because they're too expensive i
think these are both driving driving
forces here
i guess the last thing i would say is
there is a conspicuous oddness to the
together trial which i haven't heard
discussed in this last phase which is
that it
oddly
given what it did here with ivermectin
concluded that fluvoxamine was highly
effective
right
now my point would be and that result
was then published within a couple of
weeks back in august yeah immediately
um
so here's the question that did not as
far as i'm aware radically changed the
standard of care so that people who had
covet were getting flu vaccine
why didn't it if the idea is well we'd
give him ivermectin if a randomized
controlled trial said it worked
okay it did with fluvox i mean what
happened to that
right so anyway i don't i'd be
interested to hear what the answer is on
that front but i think the point is
all of this looks like
um you know the little people the riff
raff and by the riff raff i mean us
right need to be placated or dismissed
in some way and there's going to be
enough science looking stuff to make
that happen
and um
the most annoying thing is that when we
try to hold them to any standard
whatsoever it's obvious that they're not
adhering to one right are there a whole
lot of people wearing scientist hats
science-ish hats yeah exactly
[Music]
you